wir ran stolz deutschland war stolz auf
diesen papst benedikt doch jetzt das
neue missbrauchs gutachten
497 missbrauchsfälle im erzbistum
münchen und freising also dort wo joseph
ratzinger erzbischof war
dann erdbeben das durch die katholische
kirche
dieses dokument über sexuellen
missbrauch wirft neue schatten auf
unseren experten benedikt den
sechzehnten und belastet ihn schwer der
vorwurf in vier missbrauchsfällen soll
er als damaliger erbschaften nichts
unternommen haben in zwei fällen blieben
die täter sogar weiterhin seelsorger in
insgesamt vier fällen sind wir zu der
einschätzung gelangt dass dem damaligen
erzbischof kardinal ratzinger in fällen
sexuellen missbrauchs ein fehlverhalten
vorzuwerfen ist
zwei dieser fälle betreffen während
seiner amtszeit begangenen
und staatlicherseits strafrechtlich
sanktionierte missbrauchs taten der
emeritierte papst betreute nach dem
gutachten schock und charme weist in
einer stellungnahme aber alle vorwürfe
von sich wir erhalten die aussage oder
die angabe des papstes benedikt er sei
in dieser sitzung nicht anwesend gewesen
als wenig glaubwürdig jetzt wird
klartext gefordert am 19 januar
versammelten sich gläubiger in münchen
und zeigten ihre solidarität gegenüber
den missbrauchsopfern
insgesamt wurden in dem gutachten
497 missbrauchsopfer und 235 mutmaßliche
täter im zeitraum von 1945 bis 2009 10
ermittelt
über diesen missbrauch müssen wir reden
hier bei bild und das tun wir mit
unserem bild papst experten mit albert
link rüstig albert hallo die
entscheidende frage in diesem fall wie
viel missbrauch verantwortet unser papst
benedikt
ich glaube
der schock bezieht sich schon darauf
dass er weiß dass die ganze welt jetzt
das gutachten kennt und das ganz klar
ist von diesen 497 fällen wir haben
einige nicht geschehen wenn er in seiner
zeit als erzbischof
genauer hingeschaut hätte und härter
durchgegriffen hätte
wie er es später als papst versucht hat
aber ganz offensichtlich eben in seiner
aufgabe als bischof in einigen fällen
nicht getan hat wegen dieser
verantwortung glaubst du dann auch
zurück zu guild getreten
der rücktritt hat er mit dem
missbrauchsskandal zu tun ganz ohne 2
für den der missbrauchsskandal hat die
letzten drei jahre zumindest vielleicht
auch schon vorher das pontifikat zu
überschattet und es hat ihn natürlich
zurück und kraft gekostet bei jeder
auslandsreise war es das wichtigste
thema wollten die journalisten vorher
wissen was ist denn wird der opfer
treffen wird er sich entschuldigen und
benedikt hat wirklich etwas getan was
wir merken es wert war hat immer gesagt
jawohl das sind keine angriffe von außen
das ist unsere fehler es ist unsere
charme er hat härteste worte benutzt
wert von abscheulichen verbrechen
gesprochen er hat von einer perversion
des priesteramtes gesprochen und er hat
was man ihm auch zugestehen muss anders
als sein vorgänger hunderte von
priestern auch aus dem amt entfernt die
zweifelsfrei als täter entlarvt waren
aber all das hat kraft gekostet ging
gegen widerstände und ehrlicherweise
muss man natürlich aus heutiger sicht
auch sagen
war es trotzdem nicht genug man hätte
noch härter durchgreifen müssen
das dilemma der kirche dass sich bis zum
heutigen tag zieht nun gibt es diese
worte charme und schock die von ihm
verbreitet werden von papst benedikt als
aktuelle reaktion aber die sehen wir ihn
nicht sagen er schweigt jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit warum nicht auch wenn er
ein sehr alter mann ist mittlerweile
warum nicht sich stellen warum nicht das
sind die kamera sagen an die
öffentlichkeit gehen und uns genau diese
wichtigen worte schenken man muss wissen
dass fast verstummt ist er ist fast
nicht mehr zu verstehen beim sprechen
selbst sein privatsekretär georg
gänswein hat gegen die schwierigkeiten
das zu verstehen was
der papst sagt ich glaube es ist allein
ein bemerkenswerter zu gewissen dass er
stellung bezogen hat zu den vorwürfen
mit 94 jahren ich hatte ihm nicht
geraten wenn ich sie was die
stellungnahme beinhaltet hat das sind
dinge die klingen fast wie eine
relativierung das ist also gar kein
besonders
guter zug gewesen aber es zeigt dass er
sich sehr wohl damit nochmal
auseinandersetzt und sehr wohl gewählt
ist
das zu tun mit der stimme weil er es
nicht können ich denke schon oder ich
würde ihm so wie ich ihn kenne und die
einschätzung kenne für das mitgefühl für
die opfer ich würde mir vorstellen zum
beispiel dass er noch einmal zur feder
greift und einen brief schreibt an
zumindest an die opfer die noch am leben
sind dann natürlich bayern ist seine
heimat bayern ist münchen freising ist
sein erst bist du natürlich kann man
auch erwarten dass es so eine geste noch
gibt die frage ist natürlich
die zeit rennt ihnen ein bisschen davon
müsste das schnell zu denke ich geht es
weiter mit diesem gutachten was wird das
für konsequenzen haben wir wird das
jetzt gehandhabt innerhalb der kirche es
gibt ja schon zwei dinge die an debatten
die eine lief schon die anderes
losgetreten worden schafft die kirche
die aufarbeitung alleine oder braucht
sie doch mehr staatliche hilfe oder muss
sie sozusagen in form von einer
wahrheitskommission die
aufklärung die aufarbeitung dieser
fürchterlichen vorfälle eben auf eine
staatliche ebene
delegieren diese diskussion gab es schon
mal aber die wird jetzt sicherlich noch
mal neu entbrennen das zweite ist
natürlich was die deutsche kirche
anbelangt da ist
im zusammenhang mit dem kölner
missbrauchsfällen schon meine variante
diskutiert worden kardinal marx hat ja
schon mal seinen rücktritt angeboten
papst franziskus die frage ist ob nicht
als zeichen der demut und des neuanfangs
das passieren müsste was schon einmal
passiert im fall von chile nämlich dass
die komplette deutsche bischofskonferenz
pubs franziskus den rücktritt anbietet
dann werden natürlich nicht alle
rücktritte angenommen aber es wurde
einfach zeigen wir bekennen uns
gemeinsam zu fehlern in den nicht nur in
der vergangenheit sondern auch das macht
ja noch schlimmer nach dem erkannt
worden ist dass es die aufarbeitung
jetzt geben muss dass da einfach vieles
trotzdem und weiterhin nicht
vorangekommen ist das ist die
verantwortung von unserem im erigierten
papst benedikt an den missbrauchsfällen
in der katholischen kirche bild papst
experte albert link bei uns im studio
danke danke danke